the Capitol Rotunda is closed right now
so mr. Bush's casket can be taken to the
site of this morning's funeral the
funeral procession will travel about
five miles from the east front of the
Capitol to Washington National Cathedral
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill waiting
for the motorcade to begin Nancy good
morning good morning you know we all saw
that glorious sunset the other day as
mr. Bush's casket was carried up the
steps of the Capitol well a little later
this morning the Bush family will return
as the casket is carried back down there
will be a 21-gun salute a band will be
playing hail to the chief and then the
casket will be loaded into a hearse and
transported across the city to the
National Cathedral last night the Bush
family was here to visit the casket once
more and thanked mourners who were
paying their respects to their father we
saw President George W Bush smiling and
laughing as he spoke to some of the
thousands of people who waited in line
he even picked up a baby from a woman in
the crowd at one point holding on to it
for a few moments we saw so many other
dignitaries and his regular Americans
walk through the Capitol Rotunda
yesterday including some of the people
who were beneficiaries of the Americans
with Disabilities Act which mr. Bush
signed into law and then there was that
iconic moment when former Senator Bob
Dole age 95 came into the rotunda and
was helped out of his wheelchair helped
to salute his longtime friend and fellow
member of the greatest generation I had
a chance to speak with Neil Bush
President Bush's son yesterday he said
that one of the reasons he's come back
to this rotunda several times to visit
with everyday Americans in line is
because he just wanted to give them a
hug tell them not to have such long
faces John because he himself isn't in
mourning he's in celebration he said of
a long life well-lived Nancy thank you
that's right the Bush family and priding
themselves on their closeness but also
they move on and celebrate not a lot of
a long time with with with mourning and
sadness but in celebration CBS News will
bring you live coverage of the funeral
for President George Herbert Walker Bush
our special report begins at 10:00 a.m.
Eastern 9:00 central here on CBS